NBA in one minute week three edition  let's go I mean we got Rose bombs we got  sham bombs we got LeBron in last place  and then there's Brooklyn  I mean does the NBA ever chill I think  not let's just get straight into it are  the Los Angeles Lakers back they moved  Russell Westbrook to the bench and went  on a wait for it two-game win streak  shout out to former door Dasher Matt  Ryan  uh let's pause the drama to shout out  the best of NBA Halloween and by that I  pacifically mean Grant went defensively  Grant Williams as Batman  the West really is wild what's going on  with the Warriors take it for Wimpy  don't tell the Utah Jazz and San Antonio  Spurs that nobody here should go to  Vegas  Cleveland this is for you the Cavs are  on a six game win streak and David  Mitchell was looking like the trade of  the summer they're meshing real early  and on the Brooklyn Nets well that's  what we have time for it make sure you  guys are